Hello everybody, this is Dr. Cutters, and welcome to the chronic disease and autoimmune disease
course.
So, this is your intro video, we've got a lot of stuff to go through with this course.
And remember, like all of our courses, these are living courses, I'm going to turn for courses
that are constantly changing and growing and adding to things, that's what we're supposed
to do.
We're supposed to be constantly changing and growing and learning and expanding and bettering
our lives and other people's lives.
And that's really what our purposes, besides our made ultimate purposes to grow into the
image of God's Son, and this course is going to try to give you that information so that
you can grow.
And that being there is in all things, and to be studied, to show ourselves approved, that's
what our goal is in all these courses.
So, it's a fun stuff that we got to go through, because autoimmune disease is kind of an
enigma for so many people, and they've maybe been to so many doctors, and they've had so
many different diagnosis, and they just can't seem to get better, and it's really frustrating.
I get it.
But we're going to go through and try to unravel this, this knot of mess that symptoms and,
you know, issues that we might have, we're trying to unravel this like kind of a mess
ball of yard and roll it out so that we can really start dealing with some of these things.
We got five modules in this course, and we're going to have bonus modules too.
So, module one is going to be digging in to understanding chronic disease.
I think we need some education, so I'm going to try to, you know, give you as much education
as I possibly can.
And I do know that some of it, you know, you guys, some of you guys are going to be like,
I already know all this stuff, and you're going to be your already experts at autoimmune.
You might know a lot of you probably know more than some of the doctors that you've been
to.
And that's good.
That's what we want.
So, and some of you are just new to this, and this is going to be like drinking from a
firehouse.
So, just don't get, you know, confused, don't get discouraged, just watch the videos over
and over again till he's really starting to sink in.
I think that won't really help.
Module two, we're going to get into proper assessment, how to do a good, proper history
on yourself, and how to do, get some tests done.
If you use our services or you use your local condition, you know, it gives you some ammunition
to be able to go and tell them what you want to get done.
Because, you know, you go to your standard medical doctor and you say, I want to know if I
have it all over your disease, and, you know, you're lucky if you're going to get anything.
So, if you know what to ask for and what to look for, you're going to be more prepared
when you do seek care anywhere.
Module three, we're going to get into the progression of self-care, and how to start taking
care of yourself.
Because that's what this whole course is about, is for you to start taking care of yourself.
And module four is when we get into the steps, Dr. C's, that's me, easy peasy steps to start.
So, our easy peasy steps to start, kind of miss those, don't work, because that thing
is easy when you're making changes in your body, but we want to break it down so it's simple.
So, maybe I should change it to simple steps to start, but I like easy peasy.
So, we're going to go through those, and you're going to work through those.
Don't just get discouraged if, you know, it takes a long time to go through those, don't
get discouraged.
If you're an expert at this and you like, I've already been through these, do them again.
Go through them again.
Keep going through them until you clean up your body.
You know, you just got to keep going through them until you clean up your body.
And then module five is when we're going to get into use of rife and other modalities, and
then we'll have bonus modules too.
So, look for those coming, remember this is a living course, we're always going to be adding
to it.
We'll be studying the different phases of autoimmune disease, the different stages.
You might have multiple autoimmune diseases in different stages.
I might have stage three rheumatoid with rheumatoid nodules and a lot of inflammation in stage
one, Hashimoto's.
That's very common to have multiple things going on, and how to break that down and how
to, you know, start to look at it differently, we're going to go through this slide in detail.
We're going to look at different barriers, how to deal with healing our barriers.
That may have been a root cause of our issues, and we're going to really look at the main
component of autoimmune disease is the loss of self-tolerance.
This is the main component of all chronic disorders, is loss of self-tolerance, and how we can
build up self-tolerance and keep ourselves in a state of general remission.
And we'll go through this in detail.
So, you just stick by me and follow along with me, and I just do know that you're going
to be blessed through this.
I really do think that we are called to not be ignorant in all things, and to study,
to show ourselves approved in all things.
So that's what this is about, we're going to constantly be feeding you information to help
you grow, to become a better person, so that you can help yourself, your family, and
other people around you, and that's what's important.
All right, now I pray for you, and I'll see you in the course.